hey guys dr. Berg here now I want to do
a video on the most important
electrolyte now let me explain what
electrolyte is if you ever take salt and
put it in water and dissolve it it
disassociates the sodium and chloride
disconnect and they become two separate
minerals okay and that fluid is very
electrically conductive
so basically electrolytes have to do
with minerals that help conduct
electricity in the body so they help
with a lot of different things and so as
far as electrolytes it would be like
potassium sodium magnesium calcium
chloride x' all those minerals okay now
potassium out of all of the electrolytes
is the one that we need in very large
quantities and I was curious why is that
why do we need the potassium in such
large amounts I'm talking 4700
milligrams to 6,000 milligrams every
single day that's equivalent to 7 to 10
plus cups of salad or vegetable every
single day that's a lot
that's odd to me and no one consumes
that much but let's let's go dig further
and exactly why we need potassium
there's something in the body called the
sodium potassium pump okay and it's
built in a little protein connected to
an enzyme it forms a whole enzyme on the
surface of your cells and you have
between 800,000 to 30 million of these
little tiny pumps and their little
generators that generate electricity to
allow things to go through the cell so
they take a lot of energy to to work in
fact one third of all the food that you
eat the energy of one third of your diet
goes to running those pumps okay you
also have another pump in the stomach
called the hydrogen potassium ATPase
don't worry about the name but it's
basically another pump that's build with
potassium
them that allows you to create stomach
acid to help you digest these pumps also
our in the muscles there in the nervous
system and the pumps in the nervous
system use about 60% of your body's
caloric intake of energy so in other
words these pumps are really critically
important in exchanging nutrition
glucose amino acids and other minerals
to allow them to transport in and out of
the cell so potassium is essential for
building the pumps to allow these
functions right here they charge the
cell electrically so your cells have
certain voltage that allows things to
work and go in and out of the cell and
create different energy in fact your
energy that you have that Contrave
controls your metabolism is control
partly by this little pump so it charges
the cell electrically it gives you
energy it helps the muscles contract and
relax because it allows calcium to go
into the cell as well so it controls the
transport of calcium Wow interesting so
if you're low on something in this pump
and these pumps aren't working your
calcium is not going to relax the muscle
so you'll get muscle cramps okay from
potassium but it's really calcium but we
can't fix it by giving you calcium we
have to give you a potassium I'll get
more into that so the muscle needs this
pump the nerves to conduct electricity
need this pump desperately and fluid the
transport of fluid the hydration of your
body is controlled by this pump and your
overall physical energy okay now since
potassium is so hard to get in the diet
because people don't realize how much
they need and they're not eating enough
vegetables you can experience a set of
symptoms that I'm going to describe to
you and you might have some of these
number one fatigue fatigue can come from
a potassium deficiency because if you're
not enough if you don't have enough
potassium your cells electrically are
going to be way way way down that you
can't pump anymore and that's why when
people start eating more potassium
it has more energy the problem is if you
try to take a potassium pill it only is
comprising about 40 milligrams maybe 90
milligrams you need 4700 milligrams so
you'd have to have a whole bottle the
pills are not going to work and plus if
you took that much potassium without the
other minerals you can throw it out of
balance so you want to get your
potassium from food or food concentrates
so then we have we have energy fatigue
we have muscle fatigue so if you go up a
flight of stairs and you feel like your
legs are really heavy or you don't have
the endurance that is a potassium
deficiency nerve if the nerve is tired
your electrical impulses won't work so
you have arrhythmias you'll have an
alteration in heartbeat problems skip
beats atrial fib
that's electrolyte deficiency okay fluid
fluid retention swollen ankles that's a
potassium deficiency what do doctors do
they tell you to avoid salt big mistake
maybe you should increase potassium okay
and then overall just energy in the cell
to work correctly okay now in the
stomach if you don't have enough
potassium you can't create the acid that
you need to help digest protein and
absorb other minerals so again the
stumped the potassium is needed for the
stomach the nerves the muscles for
energy for fluid for hydration all these
things okay so now that you know that
let's talk about how you become
deficient number one reason is you don't
have enough potassium in the diet you
need to consume seven to ten cups of
vegetable or salad a day to achieve this
now I enhance this with food
concentrates a lot of times if I can't
get the out quantity and I use my
wheatgrass juice powder I take a
teaspoon of that and that will give me a
blend of a lot of potassium and
magnesium and a lot of other things to
be able to spike that sodium potassium
pump to boost my energy as well
vomiting diarrhea will also create a
deficiency surgery when you get a
surgery what happens is your potassium
just dumps because of the stress and
that's why they always give you a
potassium
be-because to replenish that potassium
stress will also decrease potassium so
in let me just grab this book right here
my favorite CIPA encyclopedia for
endocrinology we got right here adrenal
stress right here creates potassium loss
so it's stress creates a loss of
potassium through the urine okay so
sugar creates a deficiency of potassium
why because insulin is the hormone that
helps you absorb nutrients right now it
also causes everything to go into fat
and if you have a problem with insulin
like insulin resistance you can't pull
glucose into the cell and that's why
you're craving sweets by the way but see
what insulin does it's it only is acts
as a trigger for the sodium potassium
pump to trigger the absorption of
nutrients so that doesn't get triggered
so you can't absorb things so by taking
more potassium you can actually decrease
the need for insulin and that's what I
recommend for my diabetics it's very
difficult to fix diabetes without enough
potassium okay without enough vegetable
so if you have a lot of sugar that will
deplete potassium if you take potassium
it will help with cravings and decrease
your need for insulin diuretics like
like blood pressure if you're low in
potassium your blood pressure will go up
and you also have problems with calcium
not moving in the correct places so
that's why they doctors give you a
diuretic to get rid of fluid and they
give you a calcium channel blocker for
high blood pressure but they don't
recommend potassium enough potassium
there's so many people that consume
enough potassium and the blood pressure
comes down so diuretics will deplete
your potassium so they get rid of lect
relax your blood pressure stays high
salt so sodium potassium they always
work in a balanced it's the reason we're
talking about salt is that your body
will tend to conserve salt more than
potassium and also people it's have a
lot of extra salt in their diet like
naturally just eat more salt than
potassium
so they're rarely deficient in salt okay
so salt too much salt can deplete
potassium alcohol will deplete potassium
and the last one is ketogenic diets
which is interesting so you go on a
higher fat low carb diet what happens
you will deplete potassium thus the
reason why I tell you to consume more
vegetable when you do a high or high up
fat diet so you can replenish the
potassium and feel fine because a lot of
times you'll dump a lot of water from
losing a lot of fat as well when you're
burning fat or you might feel fatigued
or you might feel kind of like
constipated by adding more potassium
from the vegetable it's not the fiber
its potassium in that food that will
help flush you out and keep the liver
clean and help these pumps work a lot
better so I just wanted to kind of give
you an idea of the most important
electrolyte what it does in your body
okay that's what lights do and then also
how you become deficient and what you
need to do to correct this okay hope
this helped and I will see you in the
next video